this week on brian ross investigates
first it was usa swimming then usa
gymnastics
now it's the united states tennis
association under fire
for covering up for this sexual predator
coach after learning
he was under police investigation i was
sexually abused by this coach
from the time i was about 13 to about 15
or so
a new lawsuit alleges tennis officials
secretly banned the coach
but it was kept secret from the athletes
members and their parents
so he went on coaching they were
protecting
themselves they did not act to protect
children
plus a new book reveals the secret lives
and secret lies of well-paid private
spies
we'll talk with author pulitzer
prize-winning investigative journalist
barry meyer they work for on behalf of
companies
oligarchs hollywood producers
corporations including new details
on the private spies who created that
now debunked dossier
on donald trump and virtually all of
that has
either failed to be proven true
or has been proven not to be true plus
this week's winners and losers in the
media is chosen by the editors
of meteorite see if you agree but what
problem are they solving for
like like what all these states do we
from the law and crime trial network
this
is brian ross investments
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our friends on
facebook live i'm brian ross joined as
always by my colleague rhonda schwartz
and rhonda we begin with a troubling
story about young athletes
and their coaches we've all heard about
usa swimming and usa gymnastics
and now the allegations of sexual abuse
and cover-up
are being made against the united states
tennis association
in a new lawsuit the usta is accused
essentially
of covering up for coaches who are
sexual predators
failing to tell the athletes and their
parents what they knew
often leading to dire consequences
rhonda
the usta is the governing body for the
sport of tennis
tens of thousands of youngsters trying
to perhaps one day get a college
scholarship or even
get to the olympics this lawsuit comes
from the family of an aspiring young
tennis player who was
abused by his coach and is now coming
forward
to tell his story
there's something about hitting a tennis
ball over a net into a
box that brings me so much joy and so
much passion
stevie gould says he knew he loved the
game of tennis from the age of six
and as a young teen he started working
with a coach by the name of
norm burgas hoping tennis could lead to
a
college scholarship or more and i
trusted him just like you were saying as
i trusted him with
my game and my future my college degree
but borges who ran a tennis foundation
for young boys in northern california
and was thought of as a charismatic
leader had a
dark secret he was successful not only
grooming stevie and his family but the
entire
community around him and that's the
primary reason why he was so
successful at doing what he really
wanted to do which was molest children
i was i was sexually abused by this
coach um
from the time i was about 13 to about 15
or so
hundreds of times over those years
according to a lawsuit stevie and his
family
have now filed against the united states
tennis association
claiming officials there knew burgos was
a sexual predator
but it was kept secret from athletes
members
and their parents and they purposefully
chose to protect themselves from
liability
specifically libel lawsuits not to do
that
because again they were protecting
themselves they did not
act to protect children what stevie and
his parents were never told
was that the united states tennis
association had secretly suspended
burgess
in 2014 after receiving this memo from
local police
that the coach was under investigation
for sexual conduct with a minor
initiated via mr burgos's tennis
coaching relationship to the victim
the parents were never told that this
man was deemed to be a danger by usta
and was banned from the sport that piece
was missing so he went
on coaching all during the time that he
molested stevie he was
he was free to coach it basically
whatever tournament he wanted to go to
and no action was taken by usta
to let parents know through a simple
stroke of the keyboard or a touch of the
button it would have been that simple to
notify these people of his
of his dangerous propensities at first i
just knew that i was
around a person who i trusted
more than almost anyone else in this
world um
and yet here he was doing things to me
and telling me to do things that were
that felt so incredibly wrong but stevie
says
he did not know how to stop it i bought
in hook line and sinker
and i believe that my path
to becoming a college tennis player and
to becoming
a scholarship athlete and getting my
college degree was
based on him and based on him getting me
there
and that there was no possible way for
me to
have the opportunities and the
connections needed to
reach that level without his help what
finally led it to stop
well i got kicked out of practice one
day and
i remember thinking
i remember my mom saying you know you're
being given a great opportunity here
no matter how hard he is on you you
can't
you can't throw this away i said you
wanna know how hard he is on me
and i spilled and i
finally had enough and i finally found
the courage to speak
which sounds so ridiculous because my
mom made it so easy
i i it's so easy to talk to her yet for
some reason this
would not come out of my mouth and
and that's how i finally came out about
it to my parents to my mom
and it was the hardest conversation i've
probably ever had with them
so stevie and his parents went to the
police and the contra costa county
district attorney's office
so my supervisor paul graves said would
you be willing to
secretly record with the police
department
to meetings with defendant burgos
and get him to admit
to one engaging in sexual conduct with
you
and maybe the time periods and he agreed
he was hesitant
he was anxious but had the courage to
kind of confront mr burgos in a in a
very honest way and ask him about those
times that
you know we engaged in x y or z you know
why did we do that and
you know were you were you doing this
for me or for you burgos was convicted
on all
60 counts of sexual abuse brought
against him
and sentenced to 255 years in prison
thanks in large part the prosecutor says
to the courage of stevie
and another young man who came forward
he had extreme power over them they
thought that
if they came forward they were going to
lose everything so they
felt that their coach their mentor
someone who was so close to them
personally and to their family that
that this was your only opportunity that
they had to do this
or else it would all be taken away for
its part
it was only last year that the united
states tennis association
finally published a list of the dozens
of coaches
who have been banned for life because of
allegations they are
sexual predators in a deposition
conducted for the lawsuit
former u.s tennis official skip gilbert
who had once called the group's policies
robust
was asked by bob allard about that at
any point in time while you were
employed by usta
were you ever made aware of a procedure
whereby
a usta would notify parents
of credible complaints
made against a coach
who taught children
within usta concerning allegations of
sexual misconduct
i was not aware if we did or didn't have
that kind of policy
you fear there are more norm virgos out
there
i know there are and that's another myth
that this doesn't happen to me i'm
certain if you would ask mary and steve
gould way back when
uh this doesn't happen to me this only
happens uh
in other places the truth is predators
are everywhere and they will do whatever
they can to get access to children
and that includes sport sport like
tennis
includes many many opportunities to work
with these kids alone and we all know
that you cannot molest
children unless you're alone with them
so the answer is yes they are out there
if anybody's watching this
there are many predators i would bet
that you know about right now that you
would never think are predators
they are out there in abundance and what
we absolutely have to do
is design these systems to better
protect the kids
after stepping away from tennis stevie
gold is back on the courts
competing as a college player but still
far from recovered
from what happened it never feels like
it's over
for me to know that he's gone for life
it doesn't mean that it's that the the
the pain or that the
memories are gone it's all he'll always
still be in my head
there's there's no getting out of that
um
so to know he's in prison is good for
everyone else but there's a lot that i
have to work through
in order to be at peace
we asked the usta to respond to the
allegations made by bob allard and
stevie gold and we got this response
while we appear and while we appreciate
the opportunity to appear on brian ross
investigates
we pass on the offer thank you the offer
remains open coming up next the secret
lives and the secret lies of those
private spies
including those who created that now
infamous donald trump dossier
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law and crime
trial network
we turn now to what has become a
fast-growing multi-billion dollar
industry
that has tried to hide in the shadows
private investigators
who often work as private spies for big
corporations
hollywood celebrities and politicians
and how the dirt they dig up
often ends up on the front pages of
newspapers are on top
tv news outlets
to learn more about that we're joined by
barry meyer the former new york times
pulitzer prize-winning investigative
reporter
and the author of a new book spooked the
trump dossier black
cube and the rise of private spies mary
thanks so much for being here tonight
tell us what are private spies what do
they do what do they dig up and
who pays for it well it's a huge
industry it's boomed over the past
decade the the estimates that
are that they bring in about a million
uh one and a half
billion dollars a year they work for on
behalf of companies
oligarchs hollywood producers uh
corporations the wealthy you name it
it's a laundry list i mean essentially
they work for the powerful
the wealthy and the controversial and
what they do
is that they dig up dirt on these folks
enemies
so they can torpedo them in lawsuits
embarrass them
publicly or basically silence them
so among the clients has been harvey
weinstein yes
indeed and harvey weinstein uh hired
no less than four corporate
investigations firms
to dig up dirt on women who as it turned
out
were making factually alleged you know
factual
allegations of sexual improprieties
against him
but nonetheless you had a firm like
black cube
this israeli company whose job was to
send out operatives under fake
identities
to try to extract information from
people
under pretext that could then be used by
lawyers to undercut their claims
your book also deals with what was
called the trump dossier produced by the
firm
fusion gps what led to that who paid for
it and
where did they find out anything that
was of use or of value
it was paid for by the democratic
national committee
essentially by hillary clinton's
campaign in 2006 to
you know get political opposition
research against donald trump
uh fusion gps which was run by two
former wall street journal reporters
hired an ex mi6 agent christopher steele
who in turn hired a guy he called his
collector to go to russia
and gather uh damaging information
about donald trump fast forward to today
what we know is that the general theme
of the report
that russians were trying to interfere
with the 2016 election
was accurate but that's not what really
gave
the steele dossier juice it's not the
thing that made it a media obsession
for three years and those were the
allegations that there was
a p-type involving donald trump that
michael cohen had met with
russians in uh prague so on and so forth
and virtually all of that has either
failed to be proven true
or has been proven not to be true
and with the dossier pretty much
debunked by many
does that undercut the overarching theme
which was accurate that the russians
were trying to interfere
in the election on behalf of donald
trump well the
you know the idea that the russians were
interfering in the election was not
unique to the dossier
so the damage of you know the whatever
one
you know if you throw the dase into the
garbage ban which you might
that doesn't affect that but when it
comes to
the collusion you know the the buzzword
for years that there was collusion
between trump campaign officials and
trump
and the kremlin uh that really hasn't
panned out that well
and has it but has the debunking of the
dossier served to undercut
the truth of what really happened i
think it's
uh not only done that what it has done
more troublingly is that
it has damaged the news media
for the first three years of the trump
administration
people were chasing the dossier down
rabbit holes were obsessed by the
dossier
it filled the airways on you know both
cable networks on the left and on the
right everyone was battling over the
dossier and during that whole time
journalists weren't really digging in to
the crimes that were occurring
during the trump administration they
because anytime they did
trump and his allies would throw up well
this is just the russia hoax blah blah
blah so it had
this incredibly damaging
impact and you know one of the reasons
for writing the book
was to make it clear that as journalists
we really need to be careful about what
we write
what we report because we do not
want to inflict this kind of damage on
our profession
all right barry meyer thank you so much
for being here author of the new book
spooked
the trump dossier black cube and the
rise of private spy
mary thanks for being with us here
tonight always a pleasure brian
in a statement on its website fusion gps
says there's
nothing exotic or sinister about the
kind of
shoe leather work they do and they say
mayor meyer mischaracterizes them as
spies and media manipulators
and he says he should know better
because he neglects to mention that he
was often the one
who called us and not the other way
around
coming up next winners and losers in the
media this week see if you agree with
the choices made by the editors of
mediaite
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law and crime trial network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media
as chosen by the editors of meteorite
and we're joined by aidan mclaughlin
who's the editor-in-chief of meteorite
which
like the law and crime network is part
of the dan abrams media empire
and aiden we begin with your first
winner jonathan swan the australian
journalist
who works for axios for his interview
with liz chaney
everybody should want a situation and a
system
where people who uh ought to be able to
vote and have the right to vote can vote
and people who you know don't shouldn't
and
and again i come back to things like
what are they solving for
like it's not like what are all these
states doing
so aidan why was he chosen the winner
this week
so jonathan swann is a white house
reporter for axios and that was him
there uh confronting liz cheney over
voting laws being passed by republican
legislatures across the country
uh for axios hbo show now
the obvious point here is that liz
cheney has vocally spoken out against
donald trump's
false claims of the election the 2020
election was stolen from him
the question that jonathan swann had for
liz cheney is does she support these
efforts by republican legislatures
to change voting laws to crack down on
fraud now she said that this
fraud has been non-existent there's no
proof that there's
any sort of widespread fraud in uh in
general election
uh why are all these republican
legislators passing these laws
and she actually defended the laws uh
while saying that she didn't believe
that this fraud existed
uh jonathan swan quite rightfully
pointed out that there's a complete sort
of disconnect there
and that's why we made him winner it was
another great interview he's been known
to do them really well
particularly he's one with president
donald trump which was very popular
remarkable that an australian journalist
has become one of the top american
political reporters
your loser this week john cena the
professional wrestler and star of the
movie the fast and furious
franchise who issued an apology to the
people of china speaking in madrid let's
listen to what he had to say we put in
the subtitles
so aidan why was he apologizing and what
makes that
a losing proposition from your point of
view
so this this has been a fairly poor
start to the promotional tour of uh the
ninth installment of fast and furious
which john cena
uh is the star of uh that apology uh
which he delivered in quite impressive
mandarin
i believe was the result of one comment
he made in taiwan
on this promotional tour for the movie
he said taiwan is the first country that
can watch
this film now china considers taiwan
which is a self-ruled
democratic region to be part of china
they do not
like when people call it a country um
so that prompted a massive uproar in
china and uh
john cena took to weibo which is a
chinese platform
to deliver that apology um now it was a
fairly groveling one
and it was reminiscent of other american
celebrities sports stars over the years
who had to apologize after crossing the
line in china unless they risk losing
out on uh financial opportunities there
uh the houston rockets coach who
expressed support for the hong kong
protest
last year comes to mind uh who got in a
lot of trouble with the nba
including a rebuke from lebron james uh
who said that he did not know what he
was talking about when he expressed
support from the hong kong pro stuff
so the china is that sensitive to demand
that sort of groveling apology
yeah and you know it's not just about
things like this you know
if you're anyone who wants to make uh
money in china whether you're
a a hollywood director producer you know
south park has for years skewered
hollywood
uh for cow towing to china uh and
turning the other cheek when it comes to
this
uh their human rights abuses um yes this
will be demanded of you all right
all right okay aidan thanks so much and
thanks to all our staff here
at long crime for getting us on the air
and getting us off the air we'll see you
next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you